RIGHT. SENATE. PUBLIC SAFETY
COMMITTEE WILL BEGIN. WE HAVE
TWO BILLS UP TODAY. WE'RE GOING
TO ESTABLISH A QUORUM. PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL UP HERE. HERE.
SEYARTO, I HAVE BEEN HERE. SATO
HAS BEEN HERE. BRADFORD SKINNER.
WIENER WIENER IS HERE. YES. SO
WE HAVE SENATOR UMBERG, WHO'S
PRESENTING SB 918. IF YOU WOULD
LIKE TO PRESENT. THANK YOU,
MADAM CHAIR, SB 918 ADDRESSES AN
ISSUE CONCERNING THE PLATFORMS
BEING ABLE TO RESPOND, IN
PARTICULAR TO SEARCH WARRANTS.
AMENDMENTS TAKEN DO THE
FOLLOWING. ONE IS THE ORIGINAL
BILL IN THE ASSEMBLY SAID THAT
THE PLATFORMS HAD TO RESPOND
IMMEDIATELY. WE SUBSTITUTED IN
72 HOURS. ALSO DEALT WITH AN
ISSUE CONCERNING WHETHER OR NOT,
FOR EXAMPLE, A LAW ENFORCEMENT
OFFICIAL FROM A STATE THAT, TO
BE BLUNT, THAT THAT MAY HAVE
LAWS THAT ARE OFFENSIVE TO
CALIFORNIANS, WHETHER THEY
COULD, FOR EXAMPLE, TAKE
ADVANTAGE OF THIS, THAT WE MADE
IT CLEAR THIS ONLY APPLIES AS TO
CALIFORNIA LAW. CALIFORNIA
ENFORCEMENT, AND, WE ALSO THE
SAME, SAME IS TRUE BOTH WITH
RESPECT TO REPRODUCTIVE RIGHTS
AS WELL AS RIGHTS CONCERNING
GENDER ASSIGNMENT. Þ. AND WE
ALSO DELAYED IMPLEMENTATION
UNTIL JULY 1ST OF 2025. URGENT I
VOTE. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
WITNESSES IN SUPPORT? SEEING
NONE. WITNESSES IN OPPOSITION
LEADER HÌ. OVER THERE. GOOD
EVENING. CHAIR AND MEMBERS.
GEORGE TH¤U, SPEAKING ON BEHALF
OF ACLU CALIFORNIA ACTION IN
OPPOSITION TO SB 9818918, SOCIAL
MEDIA PLATFORMS STORE A
TREMENDOUS AMOUNT OF INFORMATION
ABOUT EACH OF US WHO WE TALKED
TO, WHAT WE'RE TALKING ABOUT,
AND WHERE WE ARE AT ANY GIVEN
MOMENT BETWEEN THE GOVERNMENT'S
EYES AND ALL THAT INFORMATION
ABOUT US. OUR TWO MAIN HURDLES,
THE FOURTH AMENDMENT AND
CALIFORNIA'S HISTORIC PRIVACY
LAWS. THESE LAWS DON'T BLOCK
POLICE FROM SEEING CRUCIAL
INFORMATION. THEY SIMPLY REQUIRE
PLATFORMS TO DO THEIR DUE
DILIGENCE BEFORE THEY HAND THAT
INFORMATION OVER. PROTECTING
PEOPLE'S RIGHTS TAKES TIME. WHEN
A PLATFORM RECEIVES A SEARCH
WARRANT, THEY MUST CAREFULLY
REVIEW IT, PERFORM A REASONABLE
SEARCH FOR RESPONSIVE MATERIAL,
AND UNDERSTAND THE SCOPE OF
THOSE RECORDS TO DETERMINE
WHETHER WHETHER THE WARRANT IS
TAILORED AS OUR LAWS REQUIRE AND
DOESN'T, FOR EXAMPLE, VIOLATE
SHIELD LAWS PROTECTING THOSE
SEEKING ABORTIONS OR GENDER
AFFIRMING CARE. THESE PLATFORMS
MIGHT ALSO WANT TO TALK TO THEIR
LAWYERS ABOUT THE BREADTH OF THE
WARRANT, AND WHY THEY WANT TO
CHALLENGE IT IN COURT. AT THE
SAME TIME, IF YOU ARE NOTIFIED
THAT YOU ARE THE SUBJECT OF ONE
OF THESE SEARCHES, YOU NEED TIME
TO READ THE WARRANT. YOU NEED
TIME TO TALK TO A LAWYER ABOUT
YOUR RIGHTS, AND YOU NEED TIME
TO DECIDE IF YOU'RE GOING TO
FILE A CHALLENGE IN COURT. BUT
GIVEN SB 918 SHORT TIMELINE, YOU
MIGHT ONLY GET NOTICE OF YOUR
SEARCH AFTER YOUR INFORMATION
HAS ALREADY BEEN TURNED OVER TO
POLICE. SB 918 72 HOUR TIMELINE
PUTS UNNECESSARY PRESSURE ON
FUNDAMENTAL PROTECTIONS.
PLATFORMS WILL BE INCENTIVIZED
INTO CUTTING CORNERS DURING
THEIR REVIEW OF WARRANTS AND
INDIVIDUALS SIMPLY WILL NOT HAVE
ENOUGH TIME TO VINDICATE THEIR
OWN RIGHTS. BECAUSE SB 918
THREATENS CALIFORNIANS
LIBERTIES, WE URGE A NO VOTE.
THANK YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE
DO WE HAVE? IS THIS MIC EVEN
WORKING, DO WE HAVE ANY OTHER
OPPOSITION LEAD WITNESSES? HI.
DYLAN HOFFMAN, ON BEHALF OF
TECHNET, RESPECTFULLY OPPOSED TO
SB 918, HAVE HAD SOME REALLY
PRODUCTIVE CONVERSATIONS WITH
THE AUTHOR. SHARE SOME OF THE
DUE PROCESS CONCERNS OF OUR
COLLEAGUES AT ACLU. REALLY
APPRECIATE THE DELAYED
IMPLEMENTATION, AND LOOK FORWARD
TO CONTINUING OUR CONVERSATIONS
IN THE NEXT SESSION TO ADDRESS
SOME OF THOSE ISSUES. THANK YOU.
GOOD AFTERNOON. DANNY CANDLE
KAISER ON BEHALF OF THE
ELECTRONIC FRONTIER FOUNDATION,
IN RESPECTFUL OPPOSITION. THANK
YOU. THANK YOU. DO WE HAVE ANY
OTHER LEAD? I MEAN, SORRY,
SUPPORT OR OPPOSE WITNESSES,
SEEING NONE WILL MOVE ON TO
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. COMMITTEE
MEMBERS? DO YOU GUYS HAVE ANY
QUESTIONS? CONCERNS? THOUGHTS?
SEEING NONE. SENATOR, WOULD YOU
LIKE TO CLOSE URGE AND I VOTE.
THANK YOU, DO WE HAVE A MOTION?
I'LL MOVE THE BILL. WE HAVE
SENATOR SEYARTO WHO HAS MOVED
THE BILL. SB 918 MOTION IS
AMENDMENTS BE CONCURRED IN
WAHAB, I HAVE AYE. SATO. SATO I
BRADFORD. SKINNER WIENER.
WIENER. I. ALL RIGHT. THAT BILL
IS ON CALL UNTIL OUR OTHER
SENATORS SHOW UP. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH. THANK YOU. THANK YOU. ALL
RIGHT. DO WE HAVE OUR OTHER
PRESENTER, ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS?
DO WE HEAR ANYTHING BACK FROM
THEM? THEY KNOW. WE WILL GIVE
ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS FIVE
MINUTES TO SHOW UP. OTHERWISE,
WE'RE CLOSING. THANK YOU.
AS AN INSTITUTION, TO JUST
CHOOSE NOT TO. CAN'T GET OUT OF
HERE. I'M GOING TO LIFT THE CALL
FOR SENATOR UMBERG SB 918.
CURRENT VOTE IS 3 TO 0. SKINNER
AYE. SKINNER. AYE. THANK YOU.
THAT BILL'S STILL ON CALL AGAIN.
WE ARE WAITING FOR ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS TO PRESENT AB 2348.
TWO MINUTES HAVE PASSED. ARE THE
ASSEMBLY'S FLOOR STILL ON? CAN
YOU CALL THEM? YES. CAN THROW
THEM OUT ON THAT ONE. DO YOU
HAVE ANYTHING TO PRESENT, JOHN,
DO YOU HAVE THE ANALYSIS? I
DON'T HAVE THE ANALYSIS. I JUST
HAVE THE AMENDMENT. SO.
IF YOU HAVE THE SENATE, IT'S TWO
MORE MINUTES FOR ASSEMBLY MEMBER
RAMOS TO SHOW UP. THANK YOU.
REALLY YOU HAVE THE BILL. ALL
RIGHT, LET'S LIFT THE CALL FOR
SENATOR UMBERG SB 918 FOR
SENATOR BRADFORD TO VOTE.
CURRENT VOTE IS 4 TO 1.
BRADFORD. BRADFORD. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL IS OUT, ASSEMBLY
MEMBER RAMOS IS ON HIS WAY. YES.
ALL RIGHT. ASSEMBLY MEMBER RAMOS
AB 2348. WOULD YOU LIKE TO
PRESENT? GO AHEAD. THE FLOOR IS
YOURS. THANK YOU. MADAM CHAIR
AND SENATORS. AB 2348 IS A BILL
THAT MAKES SIMPLE CLARIFICATIONS
TO THE FEATHER ALERT SYSTEM.
THIS BILL CLARIFIES THAT
CALIFORNIA TRIBES HAVE TO MAKE
CONTACT WITH LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCIES AT LEAST 24
HOURS BEFORE GOING DIRECTLY TO
THE CALIFORNIA HIGHWAY PATROL TO
REQUEST ACTIVATION OF THE ALERT.
THIS CAN BE SIMPLY DONE BY
CALLING 911 OR A FULL
INVESTIGATION FROM A LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT AGENCY. IF LOCAL LAW
ENFORCEMENT MISTAKENLY
DETERMINES THAT THE PERSON
MISSING IS NOT AT RISK, THE
TRIBE CAN STILL DIRECTLY REQUEST
FOR CHP TO ACTIVATE A FEATHER
ALERT. I ASK FOR YOUR AYE VOTE.
THANK YOU, I ALSO WANT TO MAKE
IT CLEAR. I KNOW YOU AND I HAD
CONVERSATIONS, A LOT OF THE
AMENDMENTS ARE NOT FROM
NECESSARILY FROM THIS COMMITTEE,
SO I JUST WANTED TO BE VERY
CLEAR ABOUT THAT CONVERSATION
EARLIER, DO WE HAVE ANY LEAD
WITNESSES? LEAD OPPOSITION
WITNESSES ME TO SUPPORT OR
OPPOSE? ALL RIGHT. WE'RE GOING
TO BRING IT BACK TO THE
COMMITTEE MEMBERS. COMMITTEE.
OKAY. SENATOR BRADFORD, WHO IS
MOVED THE BILL, WOULD YOU LIKE
TO CLOSE? THANK YOU. I ASK FOR
YOUR VOTE. THANK YOU. SO WE HAVE
A MOTION BY SENATOR BRADFORD.
MOTION IS DUE. PASS TO
APPROPRIATIONS. WAHAB, I SEYARTO
I SAY AYE. BRADFORD. BRADFORD.
AYE. SKINNER. SKINNER. AYE.
WIENER WIENER. AYE. ALL RIGHT.
THAT BILL'S OUT. THANK YOU.
MEETING ADJOURNED. THANK YOU.